the big news Kevin Love has been a dnp
the last three games of the playoffs
going back to the Boston series and here
in game one Jack what do you think this
means for Miami tonight I'm going to
give him a little bit more size he has a
stretch four you know where they call he
can go out and you know if the Joker's
ever going to switch to him keep him
away from the Batson because he is a
threat number three but
you know I'm still anxious to see how
they're going to defend the Joker what
what are they going to do they have some
good things they did in that fourth
quarter they're probably going to
capitalize off that but like you said
Matt it's a tall order and we'll see if
this works but I don't think they should
double right away I think they should
mix it up you know make Joker score four
or five backers in a row get 10 points
you don't want him to pick your part
because Joker's one of us he gonna get
his 27. you don't get his 27
aggressively or non-aggressive but you
don't want to let him get the others
involved early especially here at home
so I'm anxious to see how they play him
the next As for Kevin Love he's become
almost exclusively a three-point shooter
since he arrived in Miami and he shot it
just under 37 percent here in the
postseason what can it do for Miami
tonight just spray at the floor more I
mean he's a bigger body to go against
Joker so number one that's going to help
in the passing Lanes but the main thing
he can put a joker away from the basket
that should help bam that should help
Jimmy get to the basketball because they
didn't shoot into three rolls basically
the last game so that that's the only
difference but man the one thing about
this nugget team they don't let you make
mistakes I think it'll help because you
know the way these teams play defense
now they switch everything The Joker The
Joker just sit there like Peyton Manning
last game like well let me see what that
mismatch is he played the quarterback
the first five six seven plays of the
game uh but Kevin's gonna have to make
some threes that's the only reason he
would be in the game and to spread the
floor so he's gonna have to to me
probably make five or six threes that
Miami's gonna be successful you know
Miami was just five of 16 on wide open
threes in game one they shot it at about
48 in the Boston series and they had a
lot of open threes too that was what was
interesting even Max true's over nine
from three oh for five on wide open
threes and he talked about Kevin Love
just the threat of him out there got a
plan but you know look we don't
typically say this about a Kevin Love on
the other side but I thought Miami you
talk about taking Advan image of
mismatches or mistakes you had Vincent
guarding Aaron Gordon early and they
were able to go inside Aaron Gordon
using his size so at least Kevin Love
will give some size and maybe prevent
Gordon from getting off early but I like
this to match the size and physicality
have love out there without a bio to
start the game yeah and I and I it was
really funny with people they're talking
about perception and reality
I did a radio show for one of my friends
here in Denver yesterday he said you
know
Miami's not going to shoot that bad I
said did you actually even look at the
stats for the game he said no I didn't
look at the stretch I said the Nuggets
been shooting they he actually shot the
ball better than plus 15 on three times
in game one so this notion that
everything Miami's gonna shoot I said
the Nuggets gonna shoot the ball better
they were the team that hadn't played in
10 days so this notion that everybody's
gonna start making threes us demanded
nuggets they did not shoot the ball well
so let's hope that Miami just gonna
start making threes and gonna change the
whole outcome of the game I don't agree
with both teams shot well below their
post even averages in terms of
three-point percentage what are the
differences for Miami was the free
throws an NBA playoff record two free
throw attempts and the fact that they
weren't going to the rim and some of
that is Jimmy Butler yeah you know it
was interesting I mean
they were driving but they were driving
to pass they weren't driving to score
Jimmy Butler was getting into the paint
but wasn't even looking at the basket
you don't know if it was he just was
being tentative and he was maybe feeling
the game out he's always patient oh he
felt you know what the size was giving
me problems but he's got to be more
aggressive I gotta look just to hunt his
shot shots like that get into the paint
be efficient and of course get to the
line put some pressure on that defense
of Denver you got to draw some fouls and
Jimmy Butler won the best game I think
sometimes when you're a star you got to
be more selfish and Jimmy's got to be
more selfish uh he's you know Kenny
talked about it he's one of the most
patient guys when it comes to offensive
but he never rushes or anything like
that but when you when you're the guy
you can't be unselfish you got to be
more selfish you got to be more
aggressive that's the depression of
responsibility to go with being the best
player bam his part Jimmy Jimmy cannot
have less than 20. he has to have 20 to
25 for this team to even be competitive
in my opinion and when you look at the
Heat and I'm only having two free throws
you can take that two ways one they were
not aggressive or they weren't getting
any calls I'm gonna go with a man they
weren't that aggressive like you said
Grant getting in the lane looking for
players they just need to be aggressive
in the fourth quarter it was a little
bit too late they got more aggressive so
hopefully they'll be a little bit more
aggressive start the game today and Matt
they really got to be aggressive because
the threat of Kevin Love Is Gonna Make
The Joker have to come out you can't
leave Kevin Love Open to shoot so he's
going to automatically pull the Joker
away from the basket so that to me Jimmy
bam Caleb Martin all those guys they got
the uh you know even Kyle Lowry the lane
should be a lot open for the for the
Heat tonight with Kevin Love out there
it'll be interesting to see Butler's
approach he was a minus 10 in game one
that was the worst of any player and
I've often compared him to the Joker in
that I can't think of two stars in the
league who care less about shot attempts
but sometimes to your point sometimes
but there's a difference
The Joker got more guys who can score on
the other and they were getting they
were getting those guys going getting
you know but Jimmy can't be you got to
be selfish sometimes well you got to be
self this and you gotta impact winning
see the Joker can impact winning not
even taking a shot we talked in games uh
after game one that first quarter took
one shot late in the first quarter but
he was impacting with this play his ball
movement his assisting Jimmy wasn't
getting that done in part because guys
weren't hitting shots but he's got to
have an impact impact on this game yeah
he's got to do an early job The Joker
can get Jim is not gonna win the game
with assist right if it's going to win
the game like the Joker can win a game
with assist that's how great he is Jimmy
is gonna his he's gonna have to score
because realistically the heat don't
have a two guys
that Gonna Get You 20 a night that's him
and Bam so they have to get a minimum of
20 each now obviously Martin's important
gave Vincent's important but you're two
stars they got to get 20. that's when
you say score I don't mean score
sporadically he needs to score like he
scored in the first two series of the
30s and you know the 40s and even you
know the 50-point gave me a needs to be
super aggressive Chuck I agree with you
because you know if you're gonna let the
game come to you and you're gonna give
it to the others and they're not going
you got to get too late you know it
seems to me that their bigger problem is
on the other end of the floor it's
dealing with that guy who had the 14
assists in game one that's a record for
a first time finals participant it's a
record for a century if you go back and
look at the stupid Boston Celtics are
just going to stand around and go
one-on-one
the Denver Nuggets played to me they do
a lot like the Warriors there's so much
ball and body movement and let me tell
you something I was never a great
defender but that's the hardest thing in
the basketball to guard ball movement
and body movement and the Joker man he's
back there he's like a great quarterback
and